ganz aktuell sammeln wir immer noch die
informationen und sehen jetzt ihren
kollegen joachim herrmann den
bayerischen innenminister dort der sich
am tatort mittlerweile ein gefunden hat
und dort zu den ereignissen stellung
nehmen heute nach würzburg gekommen nach
diesen schrecklichen meldungen über
diese dramatische messerstecherei die
sich gegen 17 uhr hier zunächst in dem
kaufhaus woolworth und haben gegenüber
liegenden sparkasse ccm ereignet hat ein
täter hat hier auf eine vielzahl von
personen eingestochen
nach gegenwärtigem stand haben wir bei
der drei tote zu beklagen
fünf weitere schweres schwerstverletzte
und dann noch weitere verletzte bei den
schwerst verletzten ist noch nicht bei
allen sicher dass wir auch überleben
werden
nach dem notruf der bei der polizei
eingegangen ist wahr
die ersten polizeikräfte innerhalb
kürzester zeit vor ort und haben nur
wenige meter von der sparkasse entfernt
dann den täter durch schusswaffeneinsatz
stoppen können hätte wurde also mit
einem gezielten schuss in den
oberschenkel gestoppt
oberschenkeldurchschuss weise keine
weiteren nach momentanen stand
schlimmeren verletzungen es festgenommen
worden uns ins krankenhaus gebracht
worden und wird aktuell von der polizei
vernommen
nach dem gegenwärtigen ermittlungsstand
durchsage ausdrücklich alles mit
vorbehalten wir sind jetzt gerade mal
dreieinhalb stunden nach der tat aber
aufgrund der raschen polizeieinsatzes
für den ich mich auch nochmal hat sich
bedanken möchten eine festnahme des
täters können wir im moment sagen es
handelt sich um einen somalischen
staatsangehörigen der seit 2005 10 hier
in würzburg lebt auch den
informationen die wir jetzt gerade in
den letzten minuten noch bekommen haben
ist diese täter in den letzten monaten
schon auffällig gewesen durch
gewalttätigkeiten oder bereitschaft und
vor allen dingen psychisch aufgefallen
erst vor einigen tagen und ist dann wohl
auch
zwangsweise eine psychiatrische
behandlung eingewiesen worden
die näheren details müssen wir jetzt
natürlich in den nächsten stunden und
tagen noch klären
klar ist jedenfalls im moment jedenfalls
sieht nicht danach aus dass es noch
andere täter mittäter oder dergleichen
gibt und deshalb hat die würzburger
polizei ja schon vor einiger zeit
erklärt dass sie keine gefahr mehr
ansonsten für die stadt für die
bürgerinnen und bürger hier sieht ich
denke dass die lage so weit geklärt ist
die polizei hat allerdings präventiv ja
in den letzten drei stunden zahlreiche
zusätzliche polizeikräfte in die
würzburger innenstadt gebracht um auf
jeden fall der eventualitäten
entsprechend vorzusorgen es gibt eine
zeugenaussage aus dem kaufhaus wonach
der täter der wie mehr hin und ab von
den eingesetzten rettungskräften
geschildert worden ist mit wirklich
unglaubliche brutalität wir auf die
opfer eingestochen hat dass diese täter
bei der tat allah akbar gerufen hat
dies ist jetzt eine zeugenaussage
das muss jetzt alles in den weiteren
vernehmungen geklärt werden
aber wir haben ansonsten im moment keine
weiteren hinweise auf die
motivationslage im moment durchsucht
polizei natürlich den wohnraum des
täters es werden jetzt weitere
vernehmungen stattfinden es wird
versucht natürlich das ganze umfeld ist
es zu klären mit wie immer in kontakt
war und unter dass es hier tatsächlich
in den letzten monaten an ereignissen
gegeben hatte
aber das ist der momentane stand der
dinge mehr kann man im moment eigentlich
sagen möchte mich an dieser stelle aber
auch herzlich bedanken
bei den eingesetzten rettungskräften es
waren wirklich auch in windeseile acht
notärzte vor ort
es waren eine vielzahl von
rettungsfahrzeugen mit den
entsprechenden rettungssanitätern vor
ort so dass auch die an den drei
unmittelbar schon vor ort verstorben
wir sehen alle anderen mögliche optimal
sofort behandelt worden sind und auch
sehr schnell in die entsprechenden
krankenhäuser gebracht werden konnten
das ist insofern
einfach vorbildlich abgelaufenen dafür
möchte ich mich herzlich bedanken so mag
ich weiß das natürlich die konfrontation
mit solchen opfern brutaler gewalt auch
für die rettungskräfte für die notärzte
rettungssanitäter nicht einfach ist
sondern natürlich jetzt auch erst einmal
eine belastung bedeutet polizei und
rettungsorganisationen haben sofort die
entsprechende betreuung organisieren die
angehörigen der opfer aufgebaut aber
auch beispielsweise für die mitarbeiter
in den betroffenen betrieben die über
die hier das alles mit anschauen mussten
und für weitere zeugenaussagen bin
dankbar dass ich eine ganze reifen
würzburger bürgern dann in den letzten
drei stunden auch noch auf dem polizei
gemeldet haben als zeugen und jede
zeugenaussage jeder der was beobachtete
weitere beiträge nachhaltig leisten
damit die polizei ein umfassendes bild
und der situation gekommen
ich habe die ganze lage mehrfach mit der
polizeiführung hier in würzburg
gesprochen und
mit dem oberstaatsanwalt jetzt dass auch
der generalstaatsanwalt dazu gekommen
mit dem oberbürgermeister denn natürlich
auch sehr betroffen ist in dieser
situation her
wir müssen jetzt einerseits hoffen und
beten dass die schwerst verletzten
überleben
dass sie geheilt werden können nach
diesen schweren verletzungen und
ansonsten muss die polizei hat ihre
ermittlungen zügig voranbringen und das
ganze umfeld dieser tat klären wie es
dazu kommen konnte und was in der tat
die motivlage des täters war
[Musik]
sie hatten
einsatzkräfte an die zu dem ersten und
sie sagen liegen wir noch keine näheren
informationen vor
und dem muss die polizei jetzt in den
ermittlungen natürlich nachgehen
hab bisher irgendwelche auffälligkeiten
in puncto islamismus gegeben hat oder
hinsichtlich eben auch seine psyche oder
was auch immer wir einstellig war ja es
gibt in der tat auch die aufnahmen dass
hier auch bürger aus würzburg versucht
haben sich ihm in den weg zu stellen ihn
zu stoppen ich habe davor wirklich sehr
sehr großen respekt weil
auch wenn die polizei schnell vor ort
war natürlich mit jeder verzögerung wohl
weitere menschenleben möglicherweise
gerettet worden weil man ja auf den
videos sieht dadurch der täter einfach
abgelehnt wurde
behindert wurde auch andere loszugehen
insgesamt bereichern insofern eine
optimale reaktion der bürgerschaft mit
viel zivilcourage aber eben auch der
polizei und rettungskräfte in der sehr
sehr dankbar dafür aber ist geschehen
ist sind richtig angesprochen oder war
ich kann dazu gegenwärtig überhaupt
nichts sagen mich hat gerade erst vor
wenigen minuten die abteilung erreicht
dass die polizei in entsprechenden
eintrag öl gefunden hat dass er in
psychiatrische behandlung da eingewiesen
wurde aber wie das dann lief und wie
lange da war und so weiter kann ich im
moment noch überhaupt nicht sagen das
losverfahren
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren